you know important points raised by
caleb farley
people made a conscientious decision
whether at the pro level or at the
college level
and i do feel like
to some degree it was held against them
by football people and it's something
that caleb farley has to deal with as he
talks to nfl teams about why he sat out
for a year does it mean he doesn't love
football and it's unfortunate that that
question gets asked
look uh caleb farley actually not to
blow my own horn but he wrote a piece in
my column announcing that he was opting
out last year and he was the first one
and i remember when i spoke to him about
this at length one of the things that he
said to me and this is what he wrote
about
you know he mentioned to chris that okay
his mom had died
and he was
uh
not every day but
at least one or two days a week
he was seeing his father
after
being with his teammates
and you know
at virginia tech
in
you know an enclosed space
in off-season practices
and so he knew that a lot of his
teammates were going home and doing
whatever and then coming back to school
you know during the week and practicing
he had no idea where they were not that
i mean he's not blaming them but he's
saying i cannot risk
guys going home
and then coming back here and us being
80 or 90 people in an indoor facility
practicing i mean how is that safe in an
era of coven
and he just said i i can't do it i can't
subject my father to this and that's why
i think in my opinion
i think anybody who opts out
you really have to look at the reason
why
they opted out and you have to i know i
totally respect caleb farley for opting
out for that reason and look
all of these guys they have their
reasons you need to look at each one
individually
and one very important difference
between college football and the nfl the
nfl
promulgated very strict and clear rules
and regulations
regarding gathering of players regarding
weight room time regarding everything
that could in any way shape or form
relate to the possible transmission of
the virus and the nfl did an excellent
job in that regard the college football
programs had no such oversight they were
all left to their own devices some
schools very careful others not and i
remember when the clusters of of
outbreaks were happening
last year at the programs as they were
trying to ramp up someone from the nfl
told me look i can tell you what this is
this is weight room this is too many
people in the weight room confined space
guys breathing hard virus in the air
this is why it's happening and yeah if
you're not comfortable that your coach
is taking it seriously and if you know
the ncaa was asleep at the switch and
really had no jurisdiction to do
anything when it comes to implementing
covet protocols the only prudent thing
to do especially since you don't have a
paycheck riding on it the only prudent
thing to do is to say as much as i hate
to do this and as much as i want to play
football i can't in good conscience
justify putting myself and my family at
that risk peter
and that's why all you have to do with
every guy like
you know maybe you want to know you want
to really know why penne sewell opted
out why russian slater opted out you
know you why any of these guys opted out
and so the best thing to do is to ask
each one of them about it and look you
might determine there might be somebody
who's just
blase about football is a little bit
passive about the sport of football
maybe that's why
who knows maybe that's why somebody
opted out somewhere
but
i think you're doing your team a
disservice if you don't fully
investigate that
the uh issue also came up this week
peter because of comments that ohio
state coach ryan day made to you in
defending
justin fields against criticism that
percolated last week via dan orlowski of
espn ryan day made the comment and look
i get what he was trying to do he's
trying to support justin fields and
demonstrate how fields spearheaded many
respects the effort
to get a college football season at all
in 2020 for the big ten but there it is
the language that's highlighted in
yellow where was everybody else where
were the guys who were opting out then
you know you don't love the game if
you're doing something like that i think
day crossed the line with those comments
and
and and i think that what he did was
said out loud what most college football
coaches and probably many nfl coaches
would believe
that if you do choose to step away it is
at least some small piece of evidence
that you aren't as committed as you need
to be to the sport of football what did
you think about what day had to say
you know at the time he said it it
you know because i was really concerned
with
justin fields and i didn't really
realize what he said until i went back
and
read the transcript to our conversation
and i said
that's going to make some people sit up
and take notice
um
but
what i thought of it was that uh
that in my opinion i think a lot of
college coaches believe that
and
that they believe that it says something
about your devotion to football if you
choose to opt out especially if it if
your school
has an environment of stringent testing
and so and again look
when some players opted out
all right it's it people opted out at
different times
and some players opted out at a time
like when caleb farley opted out the
testing at virginia tech was not
stringent and i think it became more so
you know before the season started and
so i think those are the kind of
questions why you have to ask each
player
why he opted out but yeah seeing those
comments now they really make you raise
your eyebrow
when when i first realized what ryan day
said and realized that he had crossed
the line i thought he may try after the
fact to come up with some
lame flimsy excuse and i guess to his
credit he realized there was nothing
else he could say so the smart move was
to say nothing at all otherwise you
you continue to fuel the story and you
bring it to the attention to more people
and you make yourself look bad by trying
to put the toothpaste back in the tube
but the reality is because i started to
climb up onto a soapbox and say hey if i
had a kid who was getting ready to go to
college i wouldn't let him go to ohio
state given what ryan day said but you
know what he's he's the one who said
what 95 percent or more college coaches
would be thinking they just don't say it
out loud but that's just the way
football coaches are that's the level of
commitment they have and they expect
everyone else to have that commitment
too even if those guys aren't getting
paid anything close to what the coaches
are getting
i mean one of his points obviously to me
was because i asked him about you know
tell me about this petition thing that
that uh justin fields did last year and
he's the one who started talking about
how
you know he
tried to get all big ten
uh players to sign this petition
unsaid by him
you know he didn't say this but to force
kevin warren the commissioner the big
ten to change his mind because warren
you remember had said we're not playing
football this year and so justin fields
clap back at that and his whole point
was
because look
part of the the whole orlovsky theme was
you know
why isn't this guy more dedicated to
football or whatever his quote was does
he really want to be a great player
and
you know ryan day's point
was do you
do you really question a guy's desire
when you know he spent time in the off
season putting a petition together to
try to get all the players in the big
ten to come out and sign it and to
basically protest to the league office
we want to play
and then obviously you watch the
game against clemson where he takes that
you know incredible shot by the
linebacker who got ejected for targeting
in that game and then he comes back and
after that point
uh in the last 35 minutes of the game
throws four touchdowns and beats trevor
lawrence so
it's hard for me to buy
that line and i think that is what uh
ryan day was trying to say and as you
say mike he did go too far
yeah and look he definitely and
appropriately defended justin fields and
those are points that need to be made if
anyone is going to traffic in the
negativity that is always out there when
there are teams
that are hoping and wishing and praying
that they can
finagle a draft day slide so they can
draft that guy about whom they are
spreading the negativity it's the
ultimate machiavellian approach to
football and maybe jerry jones trying to
plot some ways to plant some negative
information about florida tight and kyle
pitts so he'll slide down the board this
one caught my attention chris mortenson
reporting that jerry jones is infatuated
with kyle pitts and would obviously have
to trade up at this point to get him
he's not going to be on the board at
number 10.
i i
anytime something like this makes its
way
to our consciousness
i just wonder how and why and what the
story is behind it and it could just be
another one of those situations where
jerry's locked onto a guy that no one
else in the cowboys brain trust wants
and maybe the best way to derail it is
to make it known so someone else takes
kyle pitts so the cowboys don't face
that dilemma of loading up on offense
where they already have more than enough
weapons and their defense is woefully
outmanned at this point they need to use
that 10th overall pick on not a pass
catcher
you know what's interesting i had a
general manager yesterday i
was making a round of calls yesterday
tell me this he said how interesting
would it be
if dallas traded up to six and gave
their gave up their one next year
and you know you're as you look at this
you say well let's see miami's at number
six miami already traded up you know
from you know has made several trades
three to 12 12 to six imagine if they
traded from six to ten now you know what
that would mean
for a one next year
that would mean
that they would have gone from 12 to 10
basically
for free
you know when you think about it because
they would have ended up getting
exactly what they got
you know from from going going down from
three to twelve
uh and when they gave that one back to
philadelphia to get that one back to go
to uh uh dallas at 10. it would be
hilarious that miami is it miami has
been falling out of trees and landing on
its feet they're like the cat they're
done i think i think chris greer has
done such a great job in maneuvering
in the draft in the last couple of years
and so look i i and i don't think i
don't think miami would do it i think
they got their heart set on taking one
of the great receivers or
pits at number six but
it'd just be interesting if that
happened
well you take it a step farther i don't
know which first round pick they gave to
philadelphia to go from 12 to six but if
it's one of the picks they got from the
49ers you gave that to the eagles you
pick up the cowboys first round pick
instead that's better than a first round
pick because chances are the cowboys are
going to be drafting a lot higher than
the 49ers next year although who knows
but as we know not all first-round picks
are made the same there can be a gap of
up to 31 picks between one and another
by the time it all plays out
kyle pitts clearly a great prospect but
from the standpoint of cowboys need when
you have amari cooper when you have cd
lamb you took cd lamb last year when you
had defensive needs they've got michael
gallup they've got the weapons they've
got the financial investment in dak
prescott i don't think you justify your
financial investment in dak prescott by
ignoring your defensive needs and
loading up even more on the offensive
side of the ball so prescott can have
the kind of numbers that will make
people say they didn't get fleeced by
prescott and his agent todd france
i mean look
you know the dallas cowboys mike when i
look at the cowboys right now
um and and
you know i
i had the benefit
the year that they took dak prescott and
ezekiel elliott of you know being at
their facility and and seeing a lot of
what happened in their draft room
and the one thing that stood out
is that jerry jones
as powerful a person as he is had an
opportunity
you know five years ago basically to go
against the family
he had an opportunity
to uh
instead of giving a two and a four to
move up into the first round to try to
get paxton lynch
john schneider wanted a two and a three
and jerry was the only one who wanted to
give it the other guys in the room
didn't including his son steven the
executive vice president
but
jerry jones instead of putting his foot
down and saying darn it we're making
this trade and we're taking paxton lynch
he didn't do it
he basically sat there seethed a little
bit but he didn't do it and he just sat
there and they ended up
not
making a trade into the lower part of
the first round they stuck with their
second and third round picks
and uh and so all i'm saying is
just because jerry gets a b in his
bonnet that he wants kyle pitts
i would be very surprised if he had any
support in that room to trade a future
number one to trade up four or five
spots uh to get one player in this draft
particularly if it's not a quarterback
kyle pitts though safer than johnny
manziel the guy that jerry jones wanted
so badly back in 2014 but with that
defense and with where that team
currently is right now it's just
impossible to justify unless you trade
amari cooper for the ability to trade up
which i don't see anyone taking on a 20
million salary for cooper this year it
just doesn't make sense all right it
made plenty of sense for the jets to
trade sam darnold once they decided that
zach wilson was their guy think back to
2018 peter it was that saturday morning
trade that came out of the blue the jets
were at six they gave the colts three
second round picks to move from six to
three
now the jets get far less than that
overall investment which ultimately is
the sixth overall pick plus three second
round picks to get sam darnold they give
up
sam darnold for a sixth round pick this
year a second round pick and a fourth
round pick next year what was your
immediate assessment and reaction to the
trade that sends sam darnold to the
panthers from the jets perspective as it
relates to what they got
you know my first reaction is that um
you know
and again this is probably
it's a little bit rash but
is there any team in the nfl
over the last 10 years
that has changed coaches general
managers and quarterbacks
collectively
more often than the new york jets
browns
the patri the patriots have to be
chortling
at the new york jets
they really do because you know that
bill belichick every time somebody in
his division
changes the coach or general manager he
loves it because they're starting over
and that means that the jets are the
patriots are going to be in an advantage
so that was my first thought my second
thought was
you know
i remember because obviously i live in i
live in new york i remember when sam
darnold was picked there's a parade down
broadway this guy's gonna be the guy and
we finally have
you know the next joe namath
and and the night he was drafted and
credits steve serbia the new york post
for this mike the night he was drafted
christopher johnson you know then the
the owner in place with the jets said
i think people are going to look back 20
years from now and say that this is the
moment the jets shifted into a new gear
and became a great team
obviously
in those in the last three seasons mike
team offense new york jets 29 32 and 32.
i mean
it's
i
i i have no idea what is going on inside
the head of zack wilson right now no
idea
or his family
but i'm sure they've got to be thinking
as intelligent people man
i i i hope this joe douglas knows what
he's doing
and he's going to new york you have a
lot of draft choices right now
yeah good
he's going to new york the bar is low
robert saul is the new head coach i i
don't think there's reason for zach
wilson to go run and hide at the
prospect of being picked by these jets
and from the jets perspective you know i
say this about every team if you're
looking for a franchise quarterback and
you either have one and you know it or
you don't have one and you know it or
you have a guy that you're willing to
give him a chance to see if he becomes
one they gave sam darnold the three
years to show something that would
justify the conclusion that he's going
to be a franchise quarterback they've
made the decision he's not and now
they're rolling the dice again and you
know even though you've changed your
coach in your gm
the owner is still there kind of woody
johnson's back now but
you know you need that franchise
quarterback and if darnold didn't work
out to your level of satisfaction and
the fact that you're back in position
with the second overall pick in the
draft to take another quarterback shows
that it didn't work out with darnold
you you roll the dice again and you keep
rolling the dice until you get that
franchise quarterback so i guess you do
mike but but the question the question
is question is zach wilson is going to
be the seventh quarterback the jets have
taken
in the top two rounds in the last either
15 or 16 years
so you know at some point
don't you say
let's build a good team around our
quarterback to give him the best chance
possible to be good
and the jets just haven't done that and
and look part of that you can go back to
john itzik you can go back to uh
you know obviously you go back to mike
mcagnin
but
you know they have not surrounded their
quarterbacks traditionally with great
players and you know mike tannenbaum did
some you know with rex ryan and they had
that really good run for a while with
mark sanchez
but other than that tell me
what have the jets done the last almost
two decades i mean it's it's been a
debacle it's been an absolute debacle
which is why in my opinion
there better be
joe douglas right now as much as you can
say zach wilson's the most important guy
joe douglas is the most important guy in
this organization for the next two years
he is for the next 13 months the next
two drafts he's the guy they did go to
back-to-back afc championship games
though they were laying somewhat of a
foundation before it all fell apart with
rex ryan and mike tannenbaum but i get
your point they need to build the team
from the inside out not the outside and
mccagnan was trying too hard to build
from the outside in douglas is trying to
build from the inside out but if they
believe in zack wilson as a potential
generational talent it gets back to what
we talked about last hour
when you see that these quarterbacks if
they're great can play for you for 15 20
years possibly you grab them it's the
most important position on the field and
you know this is a great chicken in the
egg questions it relates to great
quarterbacks how much help do you need
around you
to show that you're a franchise
quarterback i mean at some point you
become archie manning but there have
been guys who have shown us they are
great quarterbacks without a whole lot
of help around them just because they
are special talents who can
extend plays with their feet who can
throw the ball into a tight window who
can will a crappy receiver to get open
and catch the ball through repetition
and effort and leadership i i i don't
know how much help it takes around a
great quarterback
to allow that quarterback to show us
he's great and i didn't see anything
from sam darnold other than the clips
that the panthers are relentlessly
pushing on social media i didn't see
enough to get me to say this guy's a
franchise quarterback
i don't think anybody did mike and
that's
so you ask yourself
i mean look
i i'm i'm not i'm not saying that sam
darnold is going to be great in the nfl
i'm not
but what i am saying is
if you look at the offensive line
and the weapons that he has had since
he's been there it's got to be right at
the bottom of the nfl
and and i don't know what number it
would be
but their offensive line has been awful
and their skill position players
collectively have been awful
and so at some point at some point
if you don't take better players how can
you expect your quarterback to be any
good
you know i haven't gone back and
researched and compared the performances
of drew brees in his years with the
chargers to sam darnold in his time with
the jets my loose recollection is breeze
was better with the charters than
darnold was with the jets but it's not
unprecedented
for for a guy for a guy who
who you know clearly wasn't good enough
in the eyes of his original team
by virtue of the fact that the chargers
drafted
well eli manning technically and then
traded him for philip rivers but they
gave up on brees after just a few
seasons kept him around and then let him
walk away and then brees becomes one of
the great quarterbacks of all time so
it's not unprecedented that a guy
was regarded as not franchise
quarterback material by his original
team and goes somewhere else and
everything falls together and lo and
behold you have a guy who's synonymous
with quarterback greatness in the nfl
and and maybe in five years we'll be
saying what the hell were the jets
thinking they had sam darnold
i i get that mike but the jets now
have in the span of 15 years
have taken six quarterbacks who they
felt at least
some degree
had a good chance to be their
quarterback of the long term future i
mean you can say well christian
hackenberg was the 51st pick
maybe but
you don't use the 51st pick in a draft
on a player if you think that he's not
going to be a starter for you
at some point
and so
the jets have taken six or seven guys
who you know they thought okay we're
taking this guy there's a good chance
this guy is going to be our future and
they're all for six
and that's the only reason why i look at
zach wilson and part of me says poor guy
and the other part says
joe douglas is the most important guy in
this franchise over the next 13 months
because these next two drafts
are going to tell whether the jets can
get on the right track
the the jets have drafted plenty of
quarterbacks you are right christian
hackenberg the second round disaster in
2016. bryce petty in 2015.
they had geno smith second round
disaster in 2013.
good god mark sanchez traded up to five
to get him now he still has four road
playoff wins an nfl record kellen
clemons they've been swinging and
missing on quarterbacks for a while and
one guy peter that they had temporarily
briefly in 2018 teddy bridgewater they
signed him as a free agent before they
traded him to the saints bridgewater is
now the other side of this carolina
panthers transaction with darnold in
bridgewater multiple teams interested in
trading for him he's got a 10 million
dollar fully guaranteed salary another 7
million non-guaranteed on top of that
he's going to have to reduce his salary
and i could see if you can if you could
get him
for 12 million in total salary maybe get
the panthers to pay two or three million
of it in a ryan tannehill type of a move
fifth round draft pick sixth round draft
pick there are spots where teddy
bridgewater could contribute in 2021 and
i fully expect that he will be traded to
someone
either before the draft or after round
one when a team like the broncos that
may be hoping that they can get a justin
fields decides all right we'll go ahead
and and do this deal to get teddy
bridgewater away from the carolina
panthers
hey mike
points bet uh has two four six eight
points bet in their nine teams is
missing the one
that i would pick
of all the teams in the league and that
is tampa bay
and i'll tell you why
before the bucks signed tom brady last
year
uh
bruce arians and byron leftwich you know
obviously they had to look at all the
quarterbacks on the market
and
i know that they
had a lot of interest in teddy
bridgewater and that they really liked
teddy bridgewater now
could they
in any way find a way to fit teddy
bridgewater salary wise on their team
i don't know the answer to that and i
don't know if they would do it but if
you ask me just my gut feeling knowing
what the landscape was 14 months ago
i would bet tampa and the and one of the
reasons if you're teddy bridgewater you
consider tampa
is that okay
i sit behind brady one or two years and
then i'm the guy
uh because who knows who the coach is
going to be of that team my gut feeling
is
maybe two years down the road three
whatever
it could be byron leftwich you don't
know
but
imagine if you were the guy to take over
for tom brady
but again
all i'm saying is that the bucks had a
lot of interest in him before they
signed brady so he's the team that's the
team that that i think would have quite
a bit of interest in him now
and and there's a simple path to tampa
and it consists of teddy bridgewater
rejecting any request that he reduces 17
million salary eventually he would be
cut i'm convinced by the panthers they
owe him 10 million fully guaranteed he
could go sign with the bucks for 1.075
million and have the panthers pay the
8.925 million dollar balance for him to
be the backup to tom brady with a
division rival i think that's why the
panthers are going to work very hard and
possibly pay
part of the salary to facilitate a trade
of teddy bridgewater so they don't have
to worry about him staying in the
division and being a member of the tampa
bay buccaneers all right let's take a
break a little which doesn't belong and
why coming up next here on pft live
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports